SPEAKER 1: Mr. Churchill,
scene 2, take 1.
WINSTON CHURCHILL:
Ladies and gentlemen,
permit me to claim
your attention.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LARRY P. ARNN: If you're
around Hillsdale for very long,
you'll find out that Winston
Churchill is important.
Why?
Churchill did things
that no one's ever done.
He was in the center of the
two greatest wars in history.
Churchill was smart,
lightning quick.
He was funny.
WINSTON CHURCHILL: I
don't often do that.
[LAUGHTER]
LARRY P. ARNN: Also,
he was eloquent.
And eloquent in a greater
profusion than I think anybody.
You know, we remember
things he said.
WINSTON CHURCHILL:
We've must now
give out all our
strength and resources
to the completion of our
tasks, both at home and abroad.
Advance Britannia.
Long live the cause of freedom.
God Save the King.
LARRY P. ARNN: He won the
Nobel Prize for Literature.
He wrote about 50 books.
He worked very hard
and very long hours.
Sometimes he'd have people with
him until 2:00 in the morning.
And he organized
his life to produce
15 or 20 hours of work a day.
And then he was
involved in everything.
So his archive is huge.
The story of his life is huge.
And you know, he became, at the
end of his life, the greatest
man in the world.
So that means that
everything in his life
becomes a subject of study.
And Churchill
understood all that.
And Churchill had
this very bright son.
And Churchill said,
wrote to him and said,
I want you to
write my biography.
So in 1961 and -2, Randolph
Churchill launches this thing.
He hired a research assistant
named Martin Gilbert.
And Randolph Churchill
died in 1968.
And Martin Gilbert,
a young historian
who'd been working
on the biography
and had published three
books already at a young age,
got picked.
And in 1977, I was
a Rotary fellow.
I had a scholarship
to go to England.
I was going to write my
doctoral thesis on Churchill.
And then one of my teachers
knew Martin Gilbert
and asked him to meet me.
And so we had a talk and,
well, he offered me a job.
August, 1977.
Two weeks later he
hired a woman who's
now my wife of almost 40 years.
And then in 2001,
darned if he didn't up
and asked me for a job
here at Hillsdale College.
And I gave it to him.
Anyway, I said, I need
to buy your papers,
because we made a deal
about 20 years ago
that if you didn't
finish the document
volumes to the biography,
we made a deal that if you
didn't finish it, I would.
Because Churchill set this up.
WINSTON CHURCHILL: We
shall fight on the beaches.
We shall fight on
the landing grounds.
We shall fight in the
fields and in the streets.
We shall fight in the hills.
We shall never surrender.
LARRY P. ARNN: The college
has the Churchill Project now,
which have just been
finished, and now number 23.
So 8 plus 23, there
are 31 volumes
in the official biography
of Winston Churchill.
We want people to understand
Churchill, first of all,
because it's just beautiful to
see some of the things he did
and understand
what produced them.
It tells you something
about the nature
of human life, as
Churchill would say,
both its triumph
and its tragedy.
But then second,
we want people who
are interested in
governments, being
leading citizens,
including politicians,
we want them to learn from this
guy who has so much to teach.
Here's something that's
done that's worthy,
that's going to have
an abiding influence.
And it's not going
to make anybody rich.
And if you want to honor
the freedom in the things
and fight for it, people who
fight for it and secure it,
and the truth, what
better way to do it?
We intend to tell the
story of Churchill
and make it
available in new ways
and keep the idea
of Churchill alive.
Because Churchill is an
example of a kind of thing
that is essential
to human nature
and helps to solve some of the
essential problems it faces.
In the moments when
things mattered a lot,
people often looked
to Churchill,
including in the moment
where they mattered the most.